we've got mark Whalberg on the phone for
the movie that's opening up Friday
November 10th back here in the Rich
Eisen show how you doing mark hey
everybody I'm hanging in there
what do you think of the Garoppolo trade
let's dive right in headfirst what do
you think I I was very surprised this
morning
you know I watching television I was
like you got to be kidding me
we got no backup now but you know
there's always a plan there's always a
purpose or whatever Bill's doing a
supportive yeah I know I look it's just
a it's a second-round pick in the back
pocket and I just don't know you don't
want to be in a position if Garoppolo
says you know I don't want to sign here
anymore and you got a franchise tag him
and suddenly he's making ten million
dollars more than the goat can't have
but you know Tom being 40 we better
bring somebody in pretty quickly after
this so what do you think of Brady
season so far mark pretty good I mean
look we could easily have lost you know
through those big intricate X's and the
Jets that call I mean he obviously has a
Patriots fan I'll take it we'll take the
ball on the 20 but that was that was
pretty crazy I thought so myself yeah I
agree with you and then you had
obviously that Texans game were Bill
O'Brien I guess forgot that that was Tom
Brady on the sideline and kicked a field
goal handed the ball back to him you
know I it's crazy because you know the
defense finally look good again um
Atlanta but then you know the offense
didn't look too good I mean you know
kick it six field goals you know this
past weekend but you know and they got
to by now hopefully though you know play
good in the second half
yeah I know which deep Mark Wahlberg
here on the Rich Eisen show which which
team scares you the most do you think
looking good thing everybody figured it
out they figure out you know everybody
always wanted to keep Rex Ryan in there
the coach to serve our purpose yeah they
look pretty good they do and I think the
playoffs is a whole different thing when
well I mean you got to get him into your
building right mark yeah exactly exactly
we're always we're always trying to scan
for
so funny because my wife has now become
the sauce with football because my son
plays tackle football for the LA City
Ducks so now you know she used to be
like I will not be in the house at the
patients are playing now she's
controlling the TV yelling and screaming
while I'm reading for the first quarter
and then I'm like she's like oh it's so
good the Dolphins well my pain oh no no
never roofer in a divisional team unless
they're playing each other and you only
root for the one with so with the worst
record we're trying to trying to school
her and how we plot and plan to go
penguin seed okay so we're just working
it all out right there how are you as a
guide watching your kid play football
mark oh man it's the best it's the best
you know they're out there they hit
pretty hard but I you know he wants to
play was one of those things where after
you know talking everybody that I know
watch a concussion and really kind of
have the lengthy discussions you know he
decided he wanted to play and I knew if
he got hit and didn't like it he
wouldn't play but he loves it so you
know I gotta let him do it okay
Mark Wahlberg here on the Rich Eisen
show and obviously you know you play and
Vince for Paulie and invincible I'm sure
you're keeping an eye on the Eagles just
seeing how that base is doing right now
I mean that kid Carson Wentz is truly
something else mark once you get to put
on the Eagles uniform and then being an
NFC team I can root for them right up
until you know god forbid we face in the
Superbowl then they know where I said
but but I am very very happy for Philly
fans with the Eagle organization it's
great so let's talk about your movie
here daddy's home - he had Will Ferrell
and yesterday and he talked about his
scenes with John Lithgow being his dad
and the interesting affection they
shared in this film what about you and
what about you with Mel Gibson
relationship not a lot of affection
being shown you know it's one of those
things where you know we laugh about how
he sent me to military school when I was
a kid and I said yeah but I was four
years old and they said well you're
wetting the bed you know he had no
tolerance for anything you know his
characters a no-nonsense guy if you
remember my characters from the first
one special special ops guy and all that
stuff so who better to play and even bad
or guide and dusty and against them yeah
we get we slowly come around because
will and I are basically you know we're
trying to pretend like everything's good
we're trying to coexist in co-parent and
then of course you know there are issues
but we keep them below the surface and
then my dad comes and starts chipping
away at that right away and takes
pleasure and you know revealing all the
issues that we have and we actually end
up hating each other more than we did in
the first war how do you keep a straight
face with will because when he was here
yesterday and full get up
I just just looking at him I just
started laughing you know what it takes
some work and it takes some time but he
definitely tried so we both tried to to
make each other laugh a lot you know
it's one of those things but I have a
different way of messing with will you
know because one thing to just kind of
make a laugh of ruinous ape there's
another thing to encourage John Lithgow
to kiss them and make out with them even
during like rehearsals and you know when
we're not rolling and Jones also being a
method actor like when they have that
scene where they have to fight you know
John's got them in a full-on headlock
and and I'm like no we need more and
kind of egging John on to make it more
believable so I think I can get in there
we'll just as soon as we can make me
laugh but him him in the costume the
manger scene was was probably the most
so you are you going trick-or-treating
with your kids later on today mark I am
doing their thing okay um so it's that
time of year where they're like okay we
want to do what we want to do so the
little ones we're taking
trick-or-treating and hopefully it's not
gonna rain today who are you going as
you don't you dressing up I'm dressing
up as Matt Damon just put on a Red Sox
shirt or a belted shirt they can't tell
if it's Mark Wahlburgers Matt Davis they
could say it's Affleck right technically
yeah I never get mistaken for Affleck
but no Matt Matt every so often so
that's how you use any who's to his
jersey you putting on all right you know
why god I have to might have to wear
number 11 for Adelman you know my son's
number 11 on the docks I might have to
Memphis done put on the sticks from my
buddy sitting it out this year so does
that does that mean your son's good in
the slot is that what you're saying - he
can he can yeah he's running back as
well can you hold
you know Barry we need a director Barry
need a director driving down sunset
there's more fun with producing a
movement princess down the street often
do you see somebody walking down the
street in Beverly not a problem
last one for you mark are you going to
lose your star ballers to the White
House what do you think oh I you know
what well not uh we got two more seasons
at least well you know what I think
there isn't anything that he can't
accomplish if he set his mind to it
certainly likeable enough I was to
referring to rob corddry who are you
referring to I'm sorry remark Oh mark
really enjoyed chatting with you as
always you take care go hang out with
your kids right back at you you got it
right back at you at mark underscore
Wahlburgers
for more Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Rich Eisen show app